Brian fearow professor biology
and curator of insects
we're going to Thompson island which is uh
just off the coast about four miles offshore
it's one of thirty four island in the boston harbor
four or five habitats we are going to cover on the island  today
lets just follow somebody
most of the insects we catch other then monarch butterfly and the big darner
dragonflies everything else is doomed
all the other adult insects will be gone by first frost
they should be sweeping
we will be collecting insects
a few weeks ahead of time
in to 100% ethanol
not a bad way to go
and we got our running pool on how many spices we will might get
a pretty good guess is a couple of hundred species
the great thing about dragonflies usually
patrol in areas on the same line
so you can anticipate where there gonna be
and uh
just wait for them
some beetles will stay in alcohol for six hours and
they basically close up everything
close up the parts and hold their breath
i might
walk back up to the meddle that we started
just spend the rest of the time getting dragon flies
but they're pretty predictable they
will run a track line basically
they do have really good vision though
thats a green gardener
thats a nice incect
they been getting quite a lot of stuff good day, beautiful